now let's take you through the very
first program that is Introduction to
bioinformatics
so for those who come from a
non-bioinformatics field let us quickly
understand what is bioinformatics and
how do we really use it
so bioinformatics is the science of both
storing lots of complex biological data
and of also analyzing it to find new
insights which we have to use in many
different ways for analysis and today's
biomedical research isn't simply about
publishing one set of results and hoping
other researchers read it it's about
finding patterns in all forms of data
linking everything that is out there to
provide new insights that we can only
spot if we can see the big picture
bioinformatics lets us bring together
the data from lots of experience in one
place so we can ask those big questions
and find the answers and such data from
different sources is available rather
than availability of such sources of
data changes the nature of the
biological research itself as it is
rapidly acquiring the character of a
data science
now who uses bioinformatics and who is
it for the answer might have been
statisticians computer scientists or
Engineers but the truth is that more and
more biologists as well as clinicians
are now expected to understand and
handle their own data to publish and
succeed in basic and translational
research in fact biology itself is
rapidly acquiring the character of a
data science
so as biology is rapidly acquiring the
character of data science that I just
mentioned billions of data points on
genes proteins and other molecules are
compiled in large files and
systematically studied and analyzing
this data leads to more knowledge and
understanding about living organisms
which includes human health
biotechnology crops and livestock so
this training program will give an
overview of bioinformatics for
understanding multi-ohomish data
analysis for students biologists and
clinicians and the influx of data that
is associated with these methodologies
and data-driven research makes
bioinformatics for Life Sciences as
prominent as the emergence of computers
is for the tech industry
now the field is based on high
throughput technologies that generates
billions of data points on genes
proteins and other molecules which
characterize biological systems and
phenomena and these data or this data
that is compiled into the repositories
and can be systematically studied to
understand interrogate and establish
trends for many applications which
includes phenomics genomics epigenetics
and also transcriptomics and what is
missing here is single cell transcript
promise
now the question is is such data
available yes and one such repository is
maintained by national Center for
biotechnology information which has a
collection of peer-reviewed Articles
biological data sets and projects on
various topics and as you can see in the
past several decades this resource has
been growing exponentially there are
over 80 000 publicly available data sets
in just one part of ncbi that is called
Geo which stands for gene expression
omnibus and this is just one simple
example of a data repository which
contains data sets on thousands of genes
in each sample but in the program we
Explore More and More of such
repositories and understand what type of
data is stored in these repositories how
we can extract it and make the most out
of it
now the program is designed to highlight
the role of big omics data that is
shaping modern biomedical Innovation
where molecular data is used for
precision Diagnostics Big Data
integration and machine learning that is
transforming personalization of
treatment selection and Innovative
algorithms that allows for unprecedented
capabilities with drug Discovery design
of large molecules and even drug
repurposed
the program will cover some of the
important Technologies and its
applications in today's world the
participants will be able to access the
bioinformatics resources along with
export and Mentor support to get help
with the learning process that will help
you learn the transformation of biology
to data-driven biology
and this was about the first program
introduction to Big Data bioinformatics
where we'll cover these aspects of
different omics analysis will get you
introduced to these different omits
analysis which includes a genomic data
analysis transcriptomic data analysis
metagenomics single cell